the other thing that's gotten carly all
fired up is a chinese social media app
called
pinduoduo china is
eating our effing lunch and this is just
another example
on this or in life in life and this this
is a
this isn't a microcosm example of why in
my opinion
so within this app is a game it's called
like
orchard the printed orchard and you like
tend to this garden you tent you like
grow your fruit it's like
you know whatever one of these kinds of
games but at certain levels you get then
free deliveries they'll just send you a
free box of fruit
so you actually win real prizes off of
the app from playing this game
so like you know it just it consolidates
like everything you want to do
in a place where you also shop so they
just are
you know they're giving you every
incentive to shop and spend more money
and it's it's fascinating
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to yank speaks everybody
guys great news back by popular demand
we're doing an episode
with the one and only carly riley uh for
those of you who maybe missed her prior
episodes
she was our former finance director um
and we've had episodes with her on
talking about crypto talking about
e-commerce talking about the future of a
whole bunch of things and we're talking
about
basically i just want our takes on where
the world's going uh but we talk about
something called a gift goat which
you're gonna have to episode figure out
what the heck that is
plus some news of the day it's carly
it's gonna be full of energy you're
gonna love this episode
um so don't miss it what the heck is a
gift coat what the heck is carly riley
up to
tune in right now yang speaks
[Music]
all right all right
welcome back everybody to yank speaks i
made a decision
and it was a decision based
on feedback from pretty much everybody
else so it's not like
on a whim it's just um but it's somewhat
of a gut call because some of my
decision data points here have been
anecdotal but the decision is to just
keep bringing back
carly carly riley who has been
what's called a recurring guest of this
show and an amazing woman
and everything the reason is because
every time she comes on everyone
generally likes seeing her and hearing
her takes but the other thing is
she's like been right a lot and
has been pointing out things or asking
types of questions that seem to keep
coming true
um if we recall
carly has predicted we did early 2021
predictions
and two of your three have like gotten
hot let's say one's 100 true
wall street bets and uh robin hood
carly riley welcome back thank you so
much love being here
so we've been doing this series on
future up every thursday
and you're not
a particular expert on the future
although everybody i've brought on
so far has always been very clear to say
like zach i'm not an expert on the
future almost every single even the
rocket scientists we brought on
uh mikael said like i'm not an expert in
the future please don't quote me on that
so i won't it's not fair to call you
that but i wanted to
talk about a number of things with you
carly today um and really i just like
getting carly's takes on a bunch of
things and i know our audience does too
so let's just do this um carly
before we dive in can you give us a
little bit on your background
like i know it very well and i think a
lot of people who
maybe followed the yang presidential
campaign um
new york background you were our finance
director like once we were big enough
for people to care about who our finance
director was
but i think you had every role on that
campaign at some point um which is why
i've always thought you're a superstar
um not thought no um so tell us about
you a little bit
oh boy all right sure so um yeah i think
my
my claim to fame is my work on yang's
presidential campaign
uh as you said i was our finance
director for the last year or so of that
campaign so just
strictly focused on fundraising but
prior to being our finance director
i did a whole lot of whatever needed to
be done uh
i joined the team really early on as you
certainly know and so
uh or so yeah it was an adventure
in uh in just like you know nobody cares
about us yet but
what can we do yeah maybe they will
someday so let's do everything we can
now to set ourselves up for that moment
um but my journey to yang was i think
interesting as i think a lot of people's
journeys to yang
were when i graduated from college where
i
did a lot of fundraising actually in
college um
as work to to get paid while i was in
school
i then i went and worked at a hedge fund
um
and so had a bit of that finance
experience there you know did not want
to stay in finance
uh i think like you recovering wall
street executive i think i put on my
linkedin
profile oh recovering yeah yeah covering
wall street bro
in my in my like call it spare time
because i was not
particularly happy in my day job i
started a show on vermont cable access
television called once upon a political
time it is a lot of taking
i want to put clips up they take it all
down well i'll i'll tell you on the side
well i don't know we'll we'll debate
with this private it was available when
she was interviewing guys
and it was like carly on this local
access tv show like
ranting daily show jon stewart style
about a whole [ __ ] ton of issues
the premise of the show was that i would
look at the history of different
political issues to better understand
where we are with those issues today
like contextualize them
what's an example of a topic um
welfare actually is the one that led me
to ubi
um which is which is relevant here but i
did government surveillance like i
actually ended up going to dc
and interviewing an nsa whistleblower
and that was the one that that freaked
out my employers they were like oh
you're gonna keep doing this thing i
feel like you shouldn't work here
i then transitioned into like call it
political media was working at a
production company
because again the hedge fund i worked at
was like yo you can't keep doing this
show and working here
so i chose the side project and
i decided to try and make some money
from it and so i
went and joined a production company
that worked on like documentaries and
sort of political media stuff
and while i was there i heard andrew
yang on the sam harris podcast
in june of 2018. and i've been like a
sam harris fan for like
you know five or six years at that point
which was kind of a long time as a
like 20 whatever year old to to be a sam
harris fan
um and was just like oh hell yeah and i
was already a ubi fan because i'd done
this
history of welfare episode that had
really illuminated to me like oh [ __ ]
like our
we don't give out like just cash anymore
to people like our welfare system is
all-in-kind benefits it's
food stamps it's you know welfare
originally started out as
money like you just it's the first the
first welfare program in the united
states was giving cash to widows of
veterans so we gave white women we gave
white women money
because their husbands had died and we
didn't expect them to work because their
husbands had died and it was raising
and sexist was so racist yeah black
people we should have said that as a
talking point on the presidential
campaign
minus the fact that it was racist and
sexist but like we've been doing
we started cash give outs cash was what
it was cash was what it was and then we
started in the 60s we added on other
programs and then in the 90s under
clinton was when we
cut a lot of cash because we gave more
power to the states to decide like
welfare systems and anyhow so i i was
just
it became it felt very clear to me after
learning about that history that
one of the biggest problems right now
was just a freaking lack of cash for
people and so i got into ubi and then
so i heard andrew on sam harris's
podcast however many months later and
was like
oh this is fascinating and i i was like
i looked him up i saw he was doing an
event
on the lower east side of manhattan i
was like okay i'm in a bar
called the skinny bar the skinny bar yep
that's where i met carly riley chris
came i was like hey
i want to work here no no no no no i
came
i came you know smooth suave casual
smooth and swampy interesting yeah the
words that are typically used to
describe me
yeah um no so i showed up to this this
event force of nature
tenacious energy
so yeah so then showed up to this event
this bar heard andrew speak and was like
like just left just like oh my god like
like kind of like i'm going to work on
this campaign like it just felt very
cosmic to me which i think a lot of us
in the early days thought about his
campaign
um but i was still fairly new to the job
i just taken at the production company
and it felt like
fairly irresponsible to just like quit
on the spot to go work for this like
no-name dude who like had this like
crazy long shot you know campaign
aspiration and you were
you were still just like a couple years
out of college right yeah i was one yeah
i was 24. yeah yeah yeah which i i i
there's no like track record of career
yeah still
you're gambling consistently with like
the
like i always thought like when you you
get out of college or your first job
sometimes you want like that blue chip
company on the resume to show people
that
i'm employable like you know um yeah i
think that's changed a bit but when i
was graduating that was like my goal and
i think that was like a common
theme you haven't even done that you're
just like no i'm carly
i have ideas you were a much more
calculated career person than i've ever
been i have nothing
because i have to make up for my lack of
intelligence
[Music]
if you've been listening to the show you
know that we've been sponsored by
helix and helix has moved outside of the
bedroom
and into your living room because they
make awesome sofas
with all form and this episode is
sponsored by all form and this sofa i've
had to sleep on this sofa at various
times because i just
pass out sometimes with watch tv it's as
comfortable as the mattress
it looks cool and it's so easy to
assemble someone as dumb as me
and is in incompetent when it comes to
building things
as myself can actually do it it's
fantastic it comes to your door
it's delivered to you super easy
assembly extremely comfortable
and you can't you physically can't stain
it maybe that's not 100
true if you really tried but i've tried
in a whole bunch of ways
chocolate food indian food i've got all
of it on this couch and it all comes out
it's amazing i freaking
love this thing if you want to find the
perfect sofa seriously the perfect sofa
check out allform.com it's freaking
awesome
and all form right now is offering 20
off
20 off all orders for our listeners at
allform.com
i love this thing you're going to love
this thing check it out allform.com
there's a whole second part to this
which i was actually writing a
screenplay
about like a woman who worked at a think
tank who was researching ubi
and so like my underlying motivation
here was like oh maybe i'll get andrew
to read my screenplay but i went to this
event it was like oh [ __ ] no like i want
to work for this campaign
did you want to work this campaign
because you thought we needed help
no i was not we did we didn't
it was one of our first legitimate it
was post sam harris we finally like gang
had a crowd and i was like
maybe this is something like maybe yeah
we did something yeah
yeah yeah um no but i left the event
went for like a 12 mile run cause i was
so like jacked up and just like hyped
and i was like well this is gonna be
like my next move um just very clear on
that for whatever reason
you guys had no job postings up um and i
was like give it a little time though
don't be
don't be like you know we barely had a
website
yeah yeah 100 to find this skinny bar
event like took digging like i just
phrased it as if like oh i just pulled
it up online like no i was like
where is he having an event and i like
had to like dig for invite
we used eventbrite at the time and we
did we continued using it because it was
a way easier event
platform than what democrats use which
is typically act blue
um because that feeds into like the
voter file and other things well they
use um
a lot of them use mobile apps right
mobilize america yeah but it's like they
all those all connect like democratic
platforms and eventbrite
uh does not it's not even close it's not
meant for that but it has like very
simple like it's great app and people
are used to it it's very easy to track
rsvp's who are using that
um like a quick sorry funny story by sam
harris though i've never heard i'm in
charge of this campaign it's early i
never heard of sam harris i know the
hell that is i
like never listened to a pod the only
part podcast i listened to shout out my
uh guys that part of my take sam harris
emails are like inbox
i believe um which and andrew frawley on
the campaign was like
oh my gosh sam harris just emailed us so
i was like
that's a good frilly impression this is
so big this is so big on
okay so then i did some research like
actually this is a big deal and i
remember so andrea at the time was like
the stump speech was
i'm gonna give it a hit or miss sort of
situation he had written this book so he
knew his stuff back to the forward so
like when people got to talk to him
they really liked him but it was not
presidential it was more like a ted talk
and uh he didn't really prepare
he didn't have to he always knew his
stuff but he wasn't like preparing me a
politician and i remember like
grabbing him it's my first time as like
campaign manager like grabbing him by
the caller and directing him to do
something i grabbed my other caller like
dude i don't care what you do
but you are preparing for this like
you're studying for a test
you're gonna you're going to take you're
going to question yeah i was like yeah i
didn't study for tests either
so yeah i'm going to need it whatever
i'm going to need a different analogy
and he came in that day because if sam
harris did remote he did it in
um in the office he came in that day
with like a little shitty grin and he
was like is that
i'm prepare for this one and if you
listen to him
on sam harris he's really tight he's
really direct it's awesome and the only
other time
so that and joe rogan is what we really
really prepped for
uh like getting the red head space like
get ready to rock i mean obviously
debates and stuff like that that was
funny to me when i got
got to meet you all and you were like
yeah i don't know anything about you
know
sam and these people and i was like oh
boy um
no so yeah yeah i remember yeah oh oh i
did yeah
that was you're like have you read this
on ubi have you read this in the email i
was like
[Music]
so i don't even remember where i was in
my origin story here but bottom line is
obviously you know the ending i
ultimately well but you know before i
quit my job i
emailed zach i'd gotten zach's your i
got your card at the event and was like
yo
i have these experiences and i really
want to work for you guys
would you get on a phone call with me so
we had
budget to hire one person
and that person needed to be a
videographer because
and you got me
you were like i was like can you do
video i was like can't you do video
and you're like yeah i i have done my
show i can do some videoing
and like the short answer is you can't
like you could i guess if you really
want to be but they're adding is you
can't
no i can't you're not a video person no
this is a good story this is a good
story so um yeah so
you say okay yeah like actually good
timing you know we're looking to hire
somebody and i was also i should say
like i was so cosmically sure that like
this was all gonna go down that i was
gonna get this job
that i waited like i waited two weeks i
read the war on normal people then i
emailed you
and you waited like a couple weeks
before you got back to me and i would
yeah or at least with you a little bit
oh yeah you know like just
playing hard to get you know yeah
whatever um and no you guys were busy
with stuff and i think you were debating
if you wanted to hire
et cetera the ceo of linkedin
says like if i don't respond to your
email like jeff what's his name i can't
remember his name on top his name is
jeff um and he said if i don't respond
an email in 20 minutes you can
email me again because it's not going to
do it yeah you're never going that's not
how i operate
nor am i as cool as the ceo of linkedin
but well regardless i was on the phone
with a friend like a week and a half
later or something and was like you know
i really want to work for this campaign
i sent this email off to them they
haven't gotten back to me like but like
fear not i will just continue to harass
them
and i hung up on that phone call and i
had this like i was like no i've heard
back like i had this instinct to check
my email right then and like lo and
behold like 20 minutes prior you would
email me
and then i like skipped down hudson
street which is where i was when i got
that email being like oh my god it's all
happening
anyways we get we get on a pho phone
call it becomes clear that you need a
videographer
i'm like uh i kind of know how to work
final cut pro but like and very
cognizant of the fact that like i can't
like produce video quickly or animations
like i can do very limited video
but so and you're like and it doesn't
you're like you're playing it cool
you're like okay we need a videographer
but you know maybe we can find another
role like
we liked you yeah yeah yeah so you
you were going to california for like a
week or something and then you said
let's get
let's i'll get back in touch with you
basically when i'm back from california
so i was like cool
in that time while you're in california
the campaign begging people for money
the campaign posts a job posting
on the campaign instagram account for a
video person
and i felt like i had been cheated on
like i literally
my heart and stomach dropped like i just
found my boyfriend like
making out with some other woman i was
like we had this
great conversation it seemed to
go really well literally you need me
what the hell is going on here so and i
go into panic mode i'm like oh okay they
need a freaking videographer well
challenge accepted
and i like i like dropped everything i
like you know was working at the i like
was like i'm going to learn how to like
do
like adobe premiere and so i like
download the free trial version and i'm
like
putting together like an animation that
shows the difference between labor force
participation rates and
like unemployment rates which like in
the end
kind of except for like that was way too
nerdy for a presidential campaign
so regardless of that type of thing yeah
i spent an entire weekend it was like my
roommate like one of my best friends
birthday weekends and i was like okay
sarah i'm going out like i can't get too
drunk because like i gotta be back at
this thing tomorrow like this is like
the saturday night sunday spent all day
monday get up like go to work
have an email from zach you being like
hey like back in california
so yeah i think we might have like a
good role for you that's a combination
of like ops and like marketing like do
you want to come in this week
like nothing about videography like
clearly i completely overreacted and i
just like stumbled like back home that
night was like they don't need me to do
videos
like they may have a different word for
me like
i didn't need to do anything i heard
that full story from you before um
yeah what happened during that time and
there's a good start of andrew and like
kind of how he leads but not always like
andrew i've always found to be very very
instinctual
um as logical as he is he has a very
good gut
feel um i like to pride myself on that
too but he's very good at it and uh
he goes you know we're looking at we
found another videographer at the time
and but we all really liked you um
and so but we only had money to hire one
we didn't really have money higher one
frankly yeah
nothing um we're like maybe the
videographer make more money and andrew
just goes
i remember telling him this dilemma i
was like we want carly she can't do the
video
we need videography like that but
there's lots of carly can do that this
videographer i just can't do
um he remember i remember him goes like
he's like look
when you're in a startup like this you
have a vision
and you feel like someone's wants to be
there and should be there
um and the only thing stopping you is
money
um in my experience you should just go
for it
and so he's like you know what we'll
find the money and like what will find
the money means like andrew and i are
gonna have to work
harder which was a ridiculous statement
at the time because we were working
seven days a week
all day every day to find money but we
found the money um and it was obviously
your greatest hire so you end up
go you well a lot of people don't know
is carly riley built the yang gang
well well well i mean not like like
that's a zack that's a classic zakism
zack speaks in like broad strokes big
big grand statements which is a lovely
training don't let the truth get in the
way
no no i mean i was early in terms of
like the initial facebook groups
building out the initial handbook that i
mean like the
infrastructure yeah yeah you know like
phone call like uh
and we did these rallies around the
country yeah we did not have money to do
and so we had uh yang gang regional
organizers who are all volunteers
and they were amazing shout out to y'all
shout out to
i mean like christine in boston oh yeah
lacey um atlanta i'm gonna miss people
they're gonna be mad i will say well
here's what i'd say is like they know
who they are the shout out to the early
yang gang is that
zach wanted to hire an event planner
this was the only other moment this is
the other moment on the campaign that i
was like right over zack
zach wanted to hire an event planner to
like plan our rallies and i was like
this is an absurd no like we don't have
that much money don't do this
and i remember like calling you remember
like i was walking in manhattan
somewhere
and calling you and i was like between
me and the like the the fan base like
the the volunteers we have on the ground
we can make these rallies happen and you
were like that sounds ridiculous but if
you're telling me it
okay this is on you like go learn pretty
early not to doubt you
and um you would it would be so funny
we'd go to
a so you would get to a rally site the
rally would be at like
five o'clock four like six o'clock yeah
whatever time um
and you would get there like nine in the
morning and like start setting up and we
it was it was the summer or depending
where it was usually pretty warm out
um we would get there you know we would
get there
before and carly's just dripping and
sweat like just
like got our math hat on like just like
frazzled but like totally in control of
what's going on like eight people
there's a bloomberg video that covered
you like a year later essentially
but it's all about that video is like
you on a daily basis just like
million things like you're juggling all
these things and that's what um
that's what it was like um but it's um i
will say this and then we can move on to
other things
um but on the yang
2020 campaign i remember saying
to the team over and over and i think
the team hated me for it or
and maybe it was someone endearing over
time um literally over time not at the
moment at the time
i was like guys don't worry our greatest
strength is we have no idea what we're
doing
oh god don't put this in the podcast we
should
because like i mean that and like we
thought of like it is also our greatest
weakness
um but what it what did it do it like
there was no
way we could we we could win running a
traditional campaign
and because of the people that wanted to
work on it because we couldn't get
people with campaign experience like i
interviewed campaign managers people
with campaign manager experience and
campaign experience who would like uh i
won't i
can't work for you but i'll help you out
i think but there was no way we could
run a traditional campaign
because we just literally did not know
how like we just didn't know how to do
that like we've got our books on it with
this but we just never done it um
so you know from our end like the
example is
well we need to we have a big like die
hard growing fan base we should throw
rallies
like formal campaigns have an advanced
team and you hire
you get endorsers and get validators and
set up the press the right way we're
like uh we're planning flag in san
francisco
uh i hope people show up and you know
yang rally's thousands in san francisco
was a headline in the san francisco
chronicle
and i think yanmentum was the headline
in vanity fair
it is hilarious to to knowing now what
like
traditional campaigns do for rallies and
the amount of money they spend on them
to think what we were doing and the
money we were i mean our
that rally budget was like ten thousand
dollars a rally
like other campaigns will spend a
hundred thousand dollars
it was less it was less than that the
first round that was like our that was
our upper end budget i mean we didn't
always hit that but
uh you know in the early days it was you
know 1000 bucks
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by hello tushy
yes y'all i know you were missing it we
are still sponsored
by bidet company and hello tushie is the
best in the business
the days are if if you've ever done it
before it's a bit of a life-changing
experience and it saves paper
it's good for the environment it's
cleaner you save money on toilet paper
guys
you need to get your head right on this
get into the bidet
game and hello tushy owns this place
they are the kings of this and their
hello tushie 3.0 bidet is
fantastic got self-cleaning technology
it literally cleans itself
it's super cool and cuts your toilet
paper use by eighty percent pretty
freaking awesome plus 60 day risk free
guarantee so you don't like it
get back and a 12 month warranty so
here's the deal give the gift of a clean
butt
go to hellotushy.com get 10
plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners at
hellotushy.com
yang for 10 percent off hello tushie.com
yang
okay i want to talk about something um a
bit in the future so carly
has been diving into nfts and we did an
nfc episode
with the founder of open c you did a
founder of openc episode
well look keep up okay
keep up okay we are on the cutting edge
devon is great um oh god i really want
to listen to that that's awesome
i have a lot of respect for devin i have
a huge amount of strength for anyone who
builds anything like that that is my
for me in my background having built a
nonprofit and this campaign and a team
actually on wall street built something
and then humanity forward
it is hard to build anything yeah um and
frankly in many ways the government will
make it more difficult not less
difficult so
you know that's like the libertarian
conservative in me in some ways um
so um billy things are hard respect
devin but we talked a lot about like his
marketplace for nfts and where that's
going but what we didn't talk about
um is what really how this
how non-fungible tokens if you didn't
hear that episode it's great episode um
change the game uh yeah and what they
can look like from a human
that we touched on this but we didn't go
deep enough and i want and you have been
going
deep into this like carly down a rabbit
hole is my favorite carly i've spent
like
hours upon hours in the last like two
weeks
on the phone with banks and a whole
bunch of other [ __ ] all because i
wanted to buy
a what a gift goat barley
wants to spend don't tell don't tell i'm
not gonna give you a number
you can google this number if you want
to but let's just say a substantial
portion
of our collective net worth
which is not a lot um i know it's a lot
relative
to yeah very i'm very blessed that i'm a
bar in america and have a job and i've
educated but i'm not rich
asterisk privileged caveat here cool but
i'm not
a rich guy you know i made some money on
wall street and i spent it all
on sally may and it's okay just like
okay but we want to spend the little we
have on
a gift goat carly tell me
about tell us the audience here
what is a gift goat and back up all the
way like
i think i'm a good [ __ ] i'm a good
voice this is a good story for people
who maybe like
still aren't sold on the concept of nfts
because i'm not coming at this from like
a super
insider like you know developing on
ethereum blockchain love open c kind of
a perspective
i'm like very much a lay person and i'm
a lay person who doesn't even understand
like
physical art like you know i think the
the
context here is if you've heard of nfts
a little bit what you probably know
about them right is that like
they're a collectible item or they're
sort of like digital art that people buy
and trade and sell and try and make
money off of
much like people do art in the in the
call it real world
um that has always been a little bit
less interesting to me as somebody who's
not interested even in art in the real
world and has no capacity to
gauge like the value of something like i
never would have been able to tell you
that people was gonna sell for 69
million dollars like that's just i
and i never will be able to so i'm much
more interested in the ways that nfts
can be leveraged
um to create like what i would call very
real value and this is where the gift
goat comes in
so gary vaynerchuk uh some of you might
be familiar with garyvee
garyvee as he's known on the interwebs
it has a lot for those who don't know
him very popular entrepreneur
very popular influencer he's great he
found pioneered influencer if you will
um yeah yeah he was very early on the
internet started like a youtube channel
about wine
very smart guy very rich guy great
builder great marketer
keep going correct so he's launched an
nft project
uh that i got pretty excited about
because the premise was that every token
so every one of his nfts that he was
releasing
serves as a ticket to a conference he's
gonna put on for the next three years
called v-con and so the idea was if you
buy this token
that that token gives you access to the
conference for the next three years so
already right you can start to kind of
price things out like okay what does a
really good conference
typically cost a multi-day conference
what does that cost if you go to milken
it's like
10k that's like the big rich thing and
then you know what that is
if you want to if you want to take it
down from there like a tony robbins like
three-day thing who's like also kind of
a motivational speaker type like you're
looking at a couple thousand bucks
you can start to get a sense of like
what one of these conferences typically
costs and then bearing in mind that
you'll have this for three years and you
can start to be like oh wow like this
token is
you know i should likely make money on
this if it's under a certain amount
so what garyvee was promising was like a
multi-day conference over the course of
three years that's gonna be
[ __ ] badass like he was like this
conference is going to be sick i'm
pulling in all of my
like all of my connections to make this
the biggest baddest like
davos meets freaking what's the music
festival meet the young cool upcoming
like influencers or whatever so i was
like cool already i can
start to value this project in a way
that i can't regular art
um and and gary's been big on this and i
totally buy this he was like this is a
proper nft project like this is how you
can build
you build a real community around this
as opposed to like just trying to quit
cash in on like a
what's hot now thing where like other
kind of creators who have communities
you know i think have put out nft
projects that were like kind of make a
quick buck but didn't really put a lot
of thought into
how do you build a real community out of
this so and so you know he's got like a
discord channel set up which is like
full of people like just excited about
this conference
about this project yeah yeah sorry a
chat group this brings us to the gift
code so i
i bought two tokens so i now have two
tickets to vcon at like the lowest
basement price like
what are these what are these tokens
called oh my happy hermit crab and my
sufficient shrimp
yep so you spent some money you bought a
happy hermit crab and a sufficient
shrimp
i spent thousands of dollars on a happy
harbor crab at a sufficient trip
tokens garyvee not an artist again
entrepreneur builder marketer drew
sketched himself so they look
and he will say this and i like garyvee
i'm not trying to knock him but they
look ridiculous they look like
i drew a pig or a kermit crab in this
case
a shrimp on the back there is a i will
defend this though there is a style to
them
okay that's fair he's consistent with
his style yes but anyway you bought a
happy hermit crab with some
i bought a happy hermit crab with for
anybody who's curious you pay you pay
ether for this stuff
um because these tokens are on the
ethereum blockchain okay so this brings
us
so as i'm i've got my first two tokens
i'm in this discord channel and i'm
getting like more and more excited about
this project in general
and um so here's the premise behind the
gift go so i should say so all of these
tokens get you access to this conference
but then there are other there are
different groups of tokens that also do
other things
on top of getting you access to the
conference and that ranges from like
one-on-one time with him in various ways
you could have them on your podcast
etc those are obviously much more
expensive and these tokens
you can resell so they can change
correct
this is i think the brilliance of his
doing each of these tokens basically
gets you something for three years
the really cool thing about that is you
could basically reap the reward for a
year
and then resell and you know recoup all
hopefully even more of your initial
investment in it and still have also
gotten whatever the
initial benefit to it was correct so so
the gift go
here we go the big the big reveal the
promise behind the gift goat is that
at a minimum of six times a year for the
next three years
garyvee and his team are going to curate
gifts at least six
that will be sent you know at random to
your home
at like random times so
it's this very fun sort of like
christmas for an adult premise
but it comes with six gifts a year yes
embedded in the smart contract right
people probably know that term
like which is what underpins these nfts
is the fact that if you
own if you're an owner of this token you
get
at least six gifts a year randomly from
garyvee
i am very convinced these gifts are
going to be sick like i think he's going
to give a car
and so to me you were looking at one
so not only will this nft hopefully have
really good resale value as people start
to understand it and are like oh [ __ ]
like you just get like six gifts
randomly delivered to your house that's
awesome
the gifts themselves if you don't want
them should likely have really good
resale value
so the opportunity to like make money
off this thing just felt
high now i don't know how much we want
to get into
we i will say this we do not have a gift
code
i don't know no it is get worth getting
into this
so so carly sells me on this gift coat
thing
because i was like all right you know
this is a cool way to invest in crypto
and get like i saw it as investment like
my old school like wealth management
situation like the mindset was like okay
you gotta buy a bunch of crypto to buy
this gift code
um the thing has value for three years
so it's a way to invest in crypt go
if if you know you're still exposed to
crypto that way but then you're all
essentially getting a dividend on top of
it the dividend being like
a gift six times a year and
theoretically these gifts can be awesome
so you could resell them yourself you
keep them yourself if they're great you
also get access to the conference you're
talking about
but we couldn't get it because
in order to i don't know basically you
have to
are you going to try and explain this
i'm going to try to find this it's going
to be fun to hear
so in order to buy cryptocurrency
there are is it you can do it through
both
two two ways right carly or you can only
do one and you have to convert to the
other one
you can do it a lot of ways okay the
main way is you go to coinbase
you make a coin based account you
transfer money in from your regular bank
into coinbase and then after a certain
period of time
there's usually a lock up period um and
depending how you get that money in the
lock-up period changes
and then you can spend it and basically
there was a basically a run on these
gift goats we had money in coinbase
we bought ethereum we bought ether
because that's how we do that's how you
get a gift go
but the money was locked up in coinbase
because i don't know
why but it takes a number of days to
validate so we couldn't actually
we had our money our money was gone but
we didn't have the ethereum
so we never got a gift goat and car and
i have been yelling at each other
probably for five days in a row
uh look if i actually explain this to
people i'm going to
you're going to lose all of your
subscribers because it's going to be
very boring
that is a fine description the only
caveat i want to give
gary if you're listening is that this
wasn't just a simple case of like
oh it was locked up for a couple days
the way it normally is
because if that were the situation i
would have we would have gotten a gift
goat
this was like a whole other level of
shenanigans because look
crypto is nascent it's the wild west but
like
this was not this was not like the
normal hold period it ended up being
held up for eight days
for reasons that it it doesn't matter it
should not have been so
we missed a gift goat because we didn't
get a gift
so gary if you know if you want to throw
me one
i really tried it is actually crazy i
like it is crazy though
i mean we we are borrowing eth from
somebody
to try and get this thing it was i have
done i've spent hours trying to get this
damage so so here's where we're at
um i'm gonna throw this out to the yang
gang if you want to um
if anyone wants to go anyone has like
couple eve and wants to go in on a gift
goat with us
you dm me on instagram or twitter or dm
carly she's way better about responding
that stuff anyway
um we're open gift go wait that's
hilarious to me that you're saying this
zack after everything we've been through
this week that you're
reopening worms i've been very
turned off by the gift goat saga and
it's fine but if you're game
you know still opening it i i think he's
making a bet
that nfts and the wallets
that you keep an nft in are going to be
almost like future social media where
like we all
go and check each other's wallets i see
an element to that vision that could be
true
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by better help guys i've been
doing better help
i have this counselor sarah she's
freaking awesome
i do it once a week easy to set up
i started as soon as i signed up it was
freaking it's like my steam valve i just
pull like release some steam
and so for you whether you're struggling
with depression stress anxiety anger
family conflicts whatever is in your
mind it is important to get your mind
right important to focus on your mental
health and better help is freaking
awesome
it's secure it's confidential it is
professional counseling done securely
online so i want you to start living a
happier life today and as a listener
you're going to get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp
help dot com slash
yang don't be stupid make sure you do
this think about your mental health
betterhelp.com
so what i want to get to here is i i
love
carly takes if you will um
so let's talk about some carly takes um
and i want to just like carly's
perspective on what the hell's going on
and so um there's your gift goat take
she says it's gonna be hot if you want
to get in on it do it yourself or if you
really want to be awesome
hit me up uh hurry up there is a price
at which it's awesome at a price at
which it's not that's what i want to be
careful about the prices we were trying
to get it out were awesome
so yeah we have to think if they're
still awesome awesome so
um but the other thing that's got carly
all fired up is a
chinese social media app called pin
duoduo
is that how you that's probably not how
you say it in actual manner and like
mandarin
they they may be like like they kind of
do it really fast at the end but i don't
know i don't understand
um
um so i'm the wrong person there but
tell me about this app and why it's
taking over the world
going over the world okay i think i
think it's
i recently learned about this and again
it's connected to me
actually to the nft conversation because
it's all about
social commerce right so this blending
of
our social media lives and our shopping
lives essentially or our
spending and buying lives and china
is eating our effing
lunch and this is just another example
on this or in life
in life and this is a this isn't a
microcosm
example of why in my opinion so let's
i'll start with like
the two elements of this that i think
are cool so essentially this is an app
it started off as like
almost like an agriculture buying
platform so you bought food and like
fruit and
things like that as opposed to just a
general commerce app but they've
expanded now to be in like a whole bunch
of different goods
but they they have this concept called
team buying so when you go on the
pinweld app
you see both an individual price and
then a team price
and the team price is lower basically if
you're gonna buy in bulk
right you can get it for a cheaper price
so you either then can join an existing
team
like an existing group of people that
want that that
thing or you can start your own team and
like text all of your friends and be
like yo you want to go in on a bunch of
peaches this
week with me or a bunch of vacuum
cleaners or whatever the hell you're
doing like this is a cool product
and if they're like yeah you all hop in
and now you all get a discount
on this good so but but they're tracking
all of this data
obviously and so they're starting to be
able to map social relationships they're
mapping who has more influence they're
saying like oh wow
when this person sends their friends
like something in the you know
clothing walk like clothing related
everybody clicks on it a bunch of people
buy
this person has a lot of influence and
clothing and so now the now the clothing
people instead of like going for
just the famous influencers we know they
can say okay this person has like
micro weight within their friend group
and within their social circle
we'll target them with our ads it'll be
a little bit more expensive to target
them
because they'll share with them all
right and they do it by segment so they
say this person's influential in
clothing this person's influential and
food and there's probably an algorithm
that's showing it on real time when
people are
oh wow so it goes it speaks to
how much data andrew talks about this ai
is like gets better and it's like eats
data
and so the more data you can feed it yes
the more data you can feed it
the more it grows the stronger it gets
et cetera and
this is just another area where china is
getting so much freaking data
that's really interesting and social
mapping their entire country
um and you know look there's drawbacks
too i'm not i'm not excited about this
because i'm like oh this is awesome
all this data about us is forever going
to be available but um
it is really interesting the second
component to this app that's like the
social component the social commerce
component to it
is the gamified component so within this
app is a game
it's called like orchard the printed
orchard and you like
tend to this garden you tent you like
grow your fruit it's like
you know whatever one of these kind of
games but at certain levels you get then
free deliveries they'll just send you a
free box of fruit
so you actually win real prizes off of
the app from playing this
game so like you know it just it
consolidates
like everything you want to do
in a place where you also shop so they
just are
you know they're giving you every
incentive to shop and spend more money
and it's it's fascinating i mean the
advantage i'll say the one advantage
that china has over a place like the
united states well there's many but on
something like this
is they subsidize shipping so this is
where you can have
members of a team from all over the
country and you can still get this
discounted rate and they can ship it
you know government shipping for all
their companies yeah
and it's something like that for some
reason shipping for them is is a lot
cheaper than it is for us here it's
actually there's something kind of
archaic about the fact that yeah
instagram shows us a lot of ads about
things we want to buy
but you click that ad you get taken off
of the instagram app
onto another website and that we're
gonna see that start to go away
this is my prediction is like you're
gonna see
commerce be more directly integrated
into these social media apps more and
more
where you're buying directly from that
social media platform you're not
clicking something and
being taken to another site and like
kind of moving you out of
whatever you're in it's going to become
all one experience
do we know if this is going to come to
the united states
um i don't know i don't know um
i will tell you this is a fun thing
guess how many users
they they started in 2015. guess how
many users they have
700 million wow very good 788 million oh
look at me
look at that that was impressive wow but
damn that's
that's a lot that's i mean more than the
you know like
more than double the population of the
united states use this app and i think
that's weekly users
or monthly users like that's regular
active users is like
700 plus million people craziest book
i've read
on the future of
china and ai is called ai superpowers by
uh kaifu lee and you say a couple things
so one of the things
is um china is better situated
mobile payments um than the united
states is and mobile payments are so
so valuable for ai and for data
gathering because
let's say i'm just going to chipotle and
i bought something if i do it with a
credit card there's only so much info
but if i do it with my phone
they know all the data that's on my
phone my
shopping habits my actual geo-targeted
location
my gender zip code income know all those
things right and so there's
just more data around what you're
purchasing they can tie the purchase to
who you are and your
and your buying habits and things like
that and so the united states
we went from cash to credit cards very
easily that's a rel that's an awesome
jump right like it's like okay
instead of carrying all these bills and
coins and crap like having a credit card
way easier that's awesome um
going from credit card to your phone in
the united states like
it's a bit costly to change like you
have to like put your phone on if put
your credit card in the phone like you
guys have used apple pay or other things
right
and what's the real benefit you're
probably still carrying a wallet
um it's not that much better than
carrying a credit card it's slightly
better and there's a
bit of a cost so like it's it's slowly
adopting the united states
china had never really gotten to credit
cards they were still in cash so the
difference between
cash and wechat is massive so instead of
using cash they can put their bank
account on wechat and so they've gone to
mobile payments fast and that is the big
difference in terms of how much data
they're getting ai um
and the second thing that blew me my
mind in that book
is this concept that um
kaifu lee flipped on said i love your
thoughts on it they flip he flipped on
his head the concept of
american hustle today in 2020 when he
wrote it or 2021
today not as in the movie starring
jennifer lawrence
she was in a movie called hustle
american hustle oh she's in that i
thought that was bradley cooper was the
star
and bradley cooper and jennifer
yes um i forgot choosing that you know
i'll see you i
i i i just think of other movies when i
think of her
um she and bradley cooper did like three
in a row together that was one of them
anyways continue
you think they dated that was always the
rumor i think he was in love with her
the like
sword on the street is he was in love
with her and she rejected him uh
good for her so kaipu lee said this he
basically put this notion that american
entrepreneurs or this american hustle
where like we work harder we've got that
american spirit like we're gonna kick
ass the cowboy mentality like work work
work
american ingenuity people go it's like
so
he's like you think you work hard united
states like you guys have all like in
these big startups we have at facebook
or google's you have like
you know like nap rooms and all these
cushy snacks
and like wonderful work like balances
you're talking about three day weekends
which i you know we've been a proponent
of all these things he's like
in china like you started a company like
a facebook
or any sort of startup in china you're
sleeping on the floor of the office
making no money and working all day
every day okay
let's be very clear that was what
happened at google and facebook in the
early days like do you do
like the early google guys talk a lot
about sleep but he's like this is more
ingrained in the culture as opposed to
america there's like an exception where
there's like yes people still do this
united states but this is like
everybody in the u.s in china like this
is the dna and what he said
which is even deeper than that point
because that point you can debate back
and forth but he's like
in the united states when we have a
minimum viable product
we have a product people like that's
growing we
declare victory when you create facebook
we're like
facebook's awesome zuckerberg on the
cover of forbes magazine or whatever you
want
victory we have it yay america yay mark
yay
people investing in that great company
declare victory
in china when you have a minimal viable
product they declare
war and he's like the and that's
right for sure yeah and they just start
trying stealing each other until
and the real the what he argues in the
book is at the
end of this war the company that comes
out of it because people just stealing
each other's ideas and fake and like so
someone make the example would be like
someone make
facebook.com someone would make
facebook.com
or a typo that's like facebook with 2ks
or whatever it is dot com
and a website looks exactly the same get
all the information making competitor
immediately um
and so but the companies that come out
of this
war have a bigger moat around their
business to make them
in some ways unbeatable because they've
like they've had like legit
street fights does it to exist um
so it was fascinating i mean look he
blew my mind and then he talks more
about it but like talking about the
culture
of china and how they're going to win
the ai super war
arms race if you will um mind-blowing
and this is another yeah
let me i'll say 100 i absolutely think
they're going to win the ai
arms race and it's they're they're going
to become the superpower because of it
i will say it's interesting because i
read a book many years ago called tiger
woman on wall street
about this this woman from i think
shanghai ended up going to middlebury
ended up
getting to wall street um going going
into all you know going on to wall
street whatever getting a finance job
um and she painted the lack of ip law
and the lack of infrastructure around ip
law in china as actually something that
was going to keep it from being able to
dominate the united states
this you know this was all an analysis
sort of in absence of ai this was many
years ago
but her argument was look there's no
incentive to be
like to innovate essentially in china
because the second you
sink a lot of money into r d like
research and development and you build a
great product
somebody's going to come along reverse
engineer it steal your idea so why would
you even bo
why bother why would you bother
innovating to begin with so that's why i
think we
it's a it's a double-edged sword you
know i read this book probably
i mean i don't know how long ago now
probably a decade ago and i do think
some of it
has remained true but i think that this
additional point of like okay but no
it's actually meant that like the people
who survive or the companies that
survive are like mega companies i think
clearly that's born out too and that was
that was not something i was thinking
about
we don't need this endless human
suffering of toiling the
the fields if you will or just like
we're all work work work work
work and i always thought switzerland
had it right where they like get one or
two big cash cows of new
inventions and new companies that come
out of there but they also have a great
social safety net and people are
generally content and happy now it's
easier to run a country of
how big a switzerland and like that's
someone who's you know you could argue
as a workaholic saying this
um but i you know i do think it's um
work money success they don't correlate
to happiness really
at all at a certain point um so it's
it's an interesting talk about human
experience but i love
carly's take pin to a duo keep your eye
out for that kind of general price the
way you've described this i want this
app
i want to play in get free discount or i
want to get discounted stuff maybe
instacart will get into this that'd be
great
i want to talk about news the day with
you i thought the one that was
interesting i have
two topics for you one is congress
right now has looked to
has approved um the creation of a
commission on the january
6th uh riots there are some
um but on the right that don't want to
do this that don't want to explore this
and i see your eye roll
my question is it's more of an
existential
question is like what has happened to
the united states
um where we think
a certain percentage of the country is
okay
with insurrection at our capital
um what we're talking about you know
frankly in
some of that that's coming from the
right which is historically
at least in recent decades the national
security party um
uh where what do you think has happened
where it is
okay for this type of
spitting in the face of the flag um
in the american history that way has
become okay um
is it a scarcity thing is it a um social
media brainwashing thing is it
they feel like they're being actual
patriots because they don't like the way
things are going what do you think
yeah i think that they believe
that the election was stolen and if we
reached a point in this country
where elections were clearly completely
fraudulent and we couldn't trust the
democratic party like we couldn't
trust in our democracy that would
justify an overthrow
arguably it would justify something
massive and so
i think this goes to the to in tim
alberta's article
about nikki haley he asks her a couple
times
like hey in your conversations with
trump in the aftermath
of the insurrection which nikki haley
spoke out against vehemently publicly
did you nikki haley push trump about
like
changing his stance right and saying
like stop you need to condemn this you
need to say that the election results
were real
and nikki said you know she did i guess
a little bit but then at the end of the
day like
trump genuinely believes that the
election was stolen from him so like
what is the point
um and i get that logic like i know a
lot of people hate that but like yeah
he's going to believe that these people
who stormed the capital
genuinely believe that i mean i think
it's abhorrent that so many
elected officials and republicans are
willing to just like let that
go because i think many of them don't
believe it but just don't want
the blow back on their party um so i
think
honestly all the things you've cited
right social media etc
have all played into this for sure the
sense of growing
distrust in our institutions etc etc
um but to say like how
have people become okay with this i
think it's because they
saw it they genuinely believe
that the election was stolen and so that
justifies
you know on one hand it's awesome on one
hand it's really sad
that i keep going back to andrew's book
on the war on normal people
where he talked a lot about like he made
a lot of predictive predictions where
things are going and the mindset of
scarcity where
what's yours is yours mine is mine mad
max style instead of a mindset of
abundance where there's enough for
everybody to go around
that um i think that fuels a lot of
of this of the hatred and i um
i it's not just the the january six is
one but i think you're seeing it in
other ways so you have the nba playoffs
are going on
um and there's a couple and there were
two instances
three actually um so there was one where
uh
kevin durant on the nets and um
i came in there a player on the celtics
were like literally
um and kyrie irving got in this too
they're literally like shouting like
really nasty things each other on the
court
uh the other night russell westbrook got
popcorn one of the players got popcorn
dumped on him by a fan as he was exiting
the court a mixed player i believe got
spit
or uh someone spit out on a player at a
knicks game
um and when i saw these stories and be
honest
i haven't like deeply followed them i've
seen the headlines and
seen them come across on espn frankly um
but it's frustrating to see the level of
hate we have in our hearts
as a society of fan base we're getting
rabbit we are getting
angrier and angrier um and
that was our hope with ubi frankly well
and of course there's a i think
a racialized component of it when you
talk about like a zero-sum what's yours
is like what's mine is mine there's not
enough to go around i think
to some extent both parties and but i
would say far more the republican party
has
very intentionally tried to like
race bait to to like give it even more
heat like it's not just like
you know it's like you know that other
race is taking this from you
or like that other race is going to win
and therefore you are going to lose
and i think that is heartbreaking and
it's been done
through all of [ __ ] american history
and all of history in general
we were doing this with the nat whatever
rebellion like you know like it was like
oh like you know poor whites instead of
being mad at the
rich people who are taking things from
you get mad at the black people um
or get mad at the slaves so um in any
case i uh
i think it's it's just tragic and i'll
say
we should absolutely have an
investigation into what happened on
january 6
the fact that we haven't already to meet
is
just i don't know enough about this or
how this process came about but like are
you out of your
effing mind yeah there should be an
investigation i absolutely think that
there were senior members of the
republican party who
um were probably you know aware of what
was going on in advance
because these people had weirdly inner
knowledge of
the layout of the capitol building
inside and
i just i think it's important who knows
i i do i'm a big fan of
um commissions investigating and you
know when major things happens we got
we need to figure out what happened um
so last question for you carlos i'll let
you
wrap this thing is what um what's on
your mind the next coming weeks
summer starts um uh things you're
focused on
uh i just look for you for your for
future trends things are things that you
think are gonna pop things are gonna be
problematic things will be exciting
it could be anything from fun to
political to serious to whatever
whatever you're thinking what's on your
mind oh this is a fun question
not to be a broken record but because i
do get as you know as you said
sort of down these rabbit holes i'm
looking at sort of other interesting
things
in the call it like crypto-ish space
look i i you know
i don't know if we're at the tail end of
a bubble if we're just
about to hit a new wave of um
of a bull of a you know kind of bull
market i i don't i don't have a
prediction there i don't know
um but i am thinking long term about
this stuff i think i've been looking at
this
this crypto uh called algorand which is
like an alternative
it's sort of like an alternative to
ethereum in the way that it's structured
it's
fascinating like conceptually this thing
will blow your mind um in terms of the
way it
you know seems to improve upon the
governance structure of ethereum which
i know this is like nerdy for folks who
maybe aren't as into the crypto stuff
but
so i'm reading a bunch about that i want
to continue to do that i just listened
to an interview with the um
the founder of algorand on lex
friedman's podcast
um and there's another one called
cardano that you know i
uh had gotten recommended to me somebody
told me to look into it and then like
many months later i was like oh by the
way now i'm looking into it so
reading about that so i would say those
are the two that i'm sort of
investigating in the
couple weeks to come i wish i'd like a
more fun answer like i don't know just
like
partying no that's well whatever
[ __ ] when you say that
i'm i'm interested in how we all get
vaccinated or don't get vaccinated
apparently some people are not i'm
curious i'm fascinated about the nfl
season because i think a lot of players
are many are getting back for some are
not i think it's fascinating and you
have the olympics coming up too
um this summer uh athletes are different
like i think they should um i don't
think they should be held to a standard
where they have to be this like
spokesperson politically on the vaccine
i don't think that's fair like if you're
an athlete
like what goes in what goes in michael
phelps's body
should be very and is very different
than what goes in my body i'm not an
olympic athlete
that will be a heated up discussion i
think uh well so if they don't get
vaccinated though or if there's players
that aren't getting vaccinated then they
just have to go into like a bubble
system again like they did last year
right and unlike if it should these
um organizations who are willing to get
vaccinated have to deal with a bubble
situation or should they make
are they allowed to make rules like you
can't compete unless you're vaccinated
and if they do
i mean i guess they could make that rule
is that fair i'm not sure
do you think that's there i think i
don't know like if i'm i'm vaccinated i
think people should get vaccinated um
but i think athletes are different and
it's fair for an athlete to be like
um i'm not comfortable with this and i
will stay away and wherever but the
science there's there's not science to
back up that
that idea that somehow this would be
like if like what's an example of
something that's happened to somebody
who's taken a vaccine
that would be is fine for you or i but
would be a problem for an athlete
so like it's just not pouring out like
the random horror stories which i don't
know are true or not but the biggest one
is you don't know the long-term effects
because we can't physically now i'm not
say i want to be very clear maybe
because like i'm pro-vaccine i think we
should do it but if i'm an athlete i'm
like what i do is is control what goes
in my body
um no yeah i think they should be
mandated to take the vaccines
there you go i don't think there's
enough like there's enough
any evidence here i feel like that's
just a i i don't think that because
they're an athlete it's like they have
to worry more
and let's be clear get freaking
vaccinated come on guys
of course but that's my prediction is
that you have these debates
yeah saying that stuff to take the other
side um because i think you're gonna see
it a lot
from rational people not just the far
right um or the far left
um okay carly riley
the og um the wonderful brilliant
um and wizard of the future
i don't know i think it's a dangerous uh
but a nice reputation for
joining uh thank you for letting us pick
your brain here on yang
speaks in the future we will talk soon
sounds good thanks so much
you